[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
calme-toi tu vas tout [ __ ] en l'air
pour une connerie calme-toi j'ai fini
dans le groupe
[Applaudissements]
de madame monsieur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je connaissais pas hyper bien non plus
quelqu'un que j'ai beaucoup couteau je
connais pas hyper bien c'est voilà mais
c'est vrai que ça me déçoit ça part
voilà maintenant je bois l'acheter pas
hyper fort avec lui non plus voilà on
avait préféré
je le connaissais mieux voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamais je n'aurais pensé
[Musique]
de lui
[Applaudissements]
je me sens si en vous taire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est passé d'une polémique
génial génial est-ce qu'on doit répondre
l'émission
j'adore l'émission des apnée
on va faire ça
demande-lui là ah mais demande-lui s'il
est dispo samedi je le mets à la place
de Castelnaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de notre côté de la tête
jamais entendu parler de Manhattan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
mettez
mettez le début mettez les oies ils
étaient en train de kiffer
sur scène
taper sur Google
ça va toi ça va toi mais je sais oui
pas une allez calme-toi
oui je sais c'est pour ça que je me
calme calme-toi
calme-toi là on dirait docteur Quinn fat
médecins
on dirait vraiment docteur Quinn femme
et tu t'es déjà retourné arrête oui mais
non mais tu es con
tu te retournes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans ma vie je veux choisir ma mort
aussi merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute